y la vesícula biliar es un saco en forma
de pera ubicado debajo del hígado con el
hígado se adhiere al intestino delgado a
través de una serie de tubos llamados
conductos
la bilis una sustancia producida por el
hígado para descomponer la grasa se
almacena en la vesícula biliar cuando
los alimentos grasos de una comida
llegan al intestino delgado la vesícula
biliar libera bilis sobre ellos para
ayudar a digerir la grasa
la colecistectomía es un procedimiento
quirúrgico para extirpar la vesícula
biliar por lo general se realiza cuando
hay evidencia de enfermedad de la
vesícula biliar tales como cálculos
biliares o pólipos
también se realiza para la discinesia
biliar qué es una afección en la que la
vesícula biliar no funciona
correctamente
la colecistectomía laparoscópica
requiere solo pequeñas incisiones a
través del abdomen conocidas como
puertos para llegar a la vesícula biliar
el cirujano inserta tubos llamados
trócares a través de estos puertos un
puerto se encuentra normalmente en el
ombligo o zona umbilical
se bombea gas de dióxido de carbono a
través del puerto umbilical y esto infla
el abdomen para poder observar sus
contenidos más fácilmente
a continuación el cirujano inserta en
laparoscopia a través del puerto
umbilical
las imágenes de la cámara se transmiten
a un monitor de vídeo en la sala de
operaciones mediante instrumentos que se
pasan por otros puertos
el cirujano toma la vesícula biliar
corta su conducto y arteria principal
la coloca en una bolsa de muestras y la
retira a través de uno de los puertos
después que se retiren laparoscopio se
deja una válvula de puerto colocada por
un corto periodo de tiempo para permitir
que todo el dióxido de carbono salga del
abdomen las incisiones se cierran con
suturas seguido de adhesivo para piel o
cinta de cierre para piel
si se presentan complicaciones con el
procedimiento laparoscópico el cirujano
cambiará a un procedimiento abierto con
una incisión más grande